Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Was haben wir denn heute? Freitag, ist schon Freitag.
Ist schon Freitag, der fünfzehnte sechste zweitausendzwölf, Meterebene, hier den Logbuch.
Wir rappen das hier dann irgendwann, ne? Rapnews, ja. Ja, da müssen wir eigentlich irgendwie hinkommen.
Rap-News, ja. Ja, ich mache schon so einen Rap-Kurs. Bei einer Volkshochschule, ja, ja. Yo, yo.
Ach so. Ja, die können das auch. Da kommt es eigentlich auch her, oder?
Ja ja, das direkt vom Stricken quasi.
Ja. Ja, ist eigentlich irgendwas passiert. Also ich war jetzt ein bisschen viel unterwegs und ähm habe irgendwie keine Gelegenheit, so richtig aktiv äh die Nachrichtenlage zu atmen. Unwesentlich. Äh.
Unwesentlich. Also wir haben, wir haben so viele, wir haben so viele Themen, wir haben heute zwei Gäste und äh so viele Themen, dass ich nicht zu Ende gezählt habe, aber es wird bestimmt irgendwie so eine eine große, einstellige Zahl,
und ähm das wird heute Logbuch Netzpolitik Marathon Edition.
Die Bibelausgabe sozusagen. Na dann fangen wir doch gleich mal an. Womit geht's los?
Mit unserem Gast Philipp Otto, zum zweiten Mal auf unserer Showbühne wieder zum Thema Leistungsschutzrecht, denn es hat sich was getan. Die Bundesjustizministerin hat ihren Entwurf,
für die Ausgestaltung eines Leistungsschutzrechts für Pressevorlage vorgelegt. Philipp, dein Einsatz.
Morgen.
Morgen. Frisch zugeschaltet aus der Tropfsteinhöhle des äh Leistungsschutzrechts. Wie ist es denn da jetzt mit dem Leistungsschutz.
Das ist gut, das hallt hier immer ein bisschen, aber äh das liegt vielleicht auch an dem Leistungsschutz, echt.
Ja. Also meinst, es wird nicht alles besser durch das Leistungsschutzrecht? Was ist denn jetzt konkret äh passiert? Was hat denn die Justizministerin jetzt vorgelegt?
Das Justizministerium hat jetzt den sogenannten Referentenentwurf ausgefertigt, der jetzt von den anderen Ministerien gegengezeichnet wird,
bevor dieser Entwurf dann zu einem sogenannten Regierungsentwurf wird und dann in den parlamentarischen Prozess kommt
Dieser Entwurf
durchgesickert und Info hat den gestern veröffentlicht um endlich Klarheit zu haben was denn die Pläne des Bundesjustizministeriums hier sind und was die Verleger vor allem hier fordern
beziehungsweise wie sie und was sie geschafft haben in diesem äh Entwurf reinzuschreiben,
und diesen Entwurf, den haben wir veröffentlicht und da gibt's jetzt ganz viele verschiedene Punkte, die sehr, sehr problematisch sind.
Mhm. Zum Beispiel.
Na ja, im Prinzip äh die ganzen Befürchtungen, die wir äh in den letzten anderthalb Jahren immer wieder aufgearbeitet haben, äh die wir beschrieben haben, wo wir viele Interviewpartner et cetera und Fachleute hatten, die sich dazu geäußert haben, diese ganzen Befürchtungen äh sind
Wahrheit geworden nach dem aktuellen Stand des Entwurfes heißt, ähm konkret äh das äh sehr, sehr viele unglaublich schwammige Rechtsbegriffe da.
Ähm zum Beispiel die ganze Frage von gewerblicher Nutzung. Was ist das?
Wer fällt da drunter? Es ist komplett ungeklärt, wer muss für dieses Recht bezahlen. Äh es ist ungeklärt, was fällt überhaupt unter das Recht. Ähm es sind sozusagen grundsätzliche Fragen, äh die für eine Anwendung des Rechts extrem wichtig sind, äh um in der Praxis äh diejenigen
die hier Lizenzen abschließen sollen, also im Regelfall
sind das gewerbliche Nutzer, äh das können Freiberufler sein, aber auch Suchmaschinen, äh die hier jeweils mit den Verlagen,
einen Vertrag schließen müssen, an die Lizenz abschließen müssen, um möglicherweise kleines und
und kleine Teile ähm von diesen Texten anzeigen zu dürfen äh und äh das ist eine riesige Rechtsunsicherheit, die dieser ganze Entwurf hier beinhaltet.
Klingt ja so ein bisschen als würde das äh Gesetz jetzt erstmal mehr äh die Rechtsanwälte beschäftigen dann in der nächsten Zeit.
Genau, eine der zentralen Befürchtungen ist hier genau, dass es zu Massenabmahnungen
für gewerbliche Nutzer kommt äh und insbesondere auch klar gewähren drohen, weil wenn das äh Justizministerium und der Gesetzgeber hier nicht definieren, was sie überhaupt merken, müssen das die Gerichte klären äh und bis das die Gerichte äh geklärt haben und das äh zumeist dann höchstrichterlich, heißt das dauert ein paar Jahre, äh bis dahin äh,
alles unsicher, äh bis dahin ähm kann man sich im Prinzip auch nichts verlassen äh und bis dahin setzt man sich als gewerblicher Nutzer einer
riesigen Gefahr äh von Abmahnungen aus.
Ist halt ein bisschen schockierend, dass jetzt ausgerechnet das Justizministerium eine Gesetzesvorlage auf den Tisch legt, die jetzt ähm,
unscharf formuliert ist. Also, die sozusagen die Anforderungen des Rechts an der Stelle äh etwas vernachlässigt, wichtig, richtig äh interpretiere.
Ja, das ist ist zweischneidig tatsächlich. Äh grundsätzlich äh ist es äh dem Gesetzgeber verboten, äh Einzelfallgesetze zu machen äh und äh natürlich müssen Gesetze auch immer allgemeiner
gehalten sein, um eine Vielzahl von Fällen umfassen zu können. In unserem Fall ist es aber so, äh dass das so allgemein gehalten ist
beziehungsweise sich eine Trennschärfe an entscheidenden Punkten nicht rauslesen lässt, dass dieses Gesetz sollte es kommen
zu einem völligen Chaos führen wird. Und ähm ich glaube, dass Bundesjustizministerium weiß selber nicht, wie sie die ganzen Fragen klären sollen äh und äh schicken das jetzt mal in die Welt, ähm aber das ist ähm,
Ist eine Katastrophe, dieser Entwurf äh und äh ich glaube, wenn der äh tatsächlich das Licht der Welt erblickt, äh dann ist das äh nicht nur äh eine ABM-Maßnahme für
Anwälte, äh sondern äh insbesondere äh wird das auch äh drastische Auswirkungen äh für den ganzen Bereich der gewerblichen Nutzung im Internet haben.
Der dieser Referentenentwurf, so wie wie ihr ihn da veröffentlicht habt, das ist auch die vollständige Version.
Genau, das ist die vollständige Version des Justizministerium hat das inzwischen auch nochmal bestätigt, nicht dass wir daran gezweifelt hätten, sonst hätten wir nicht veröffentlicht, weil das ist die vollständige Version, inklusive der Begründung.
Da steht ja fast nichts drin irgendwie.
Genau
Also in der Begründung steht mehr äh als in dem rein äh in dem reinen Vorschlag, äh wie die Paragraphen geändert werden sollen, äh aber äh das ist äh grundsätzlich so bei Gesetzen, dass da relativ wenig drin steht, aber in dem wenigen äh
äh verbirgt sich so viel Sprengstoff, äh dass äh dass äh kaum äh kaum äh einzupferchen ist.
Äh kriegt denn das jetzt als nächstes auf den Tisch? Also wer wer muss sich denn da jetzt noch zu äußern?
Na ja, jetzt haben das äh die Ministerien, die mitzeichnen, äh das sind beispielsweise ähm das Kanzleramt, das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium, der Bundesrechnungshof.
Das Bundesverbraucherschutzministerium et cetera, die müssen jetzt alle noch ihren Segen dazu geben und sagen, ja, das ist in Ordnung, man kann davon ausgehen, äh dass dieser Segen relativ bald kommt
zumal in diesem Fall auch 'ne extrem knappe Frist gesetzt wurde am kommenden Montag läuft diese Frist ab
bis dahin müssen alle Ministerien, die zu beteiligen sind ihr OK gegeben haben
Wenn das da ist, wovon aktuell auszugehen ist, weil es auch zu vermuten ist, dass das im vorhinein abgekaspert wurde
dann geht das geht dieser Entwurf in den Koalitionsausschuss und,
am aller Vorsicht nach am vierten Juli äh zum Regierungsentwurf und geht dann den parlamentarischen Prozess. Also alles sehr sehr zügig.
Wenn, wie kann das verhindert werden, dass das so zügig läuft, weil wenn du sagst, das ist so ein schlechter Entwurf ist, dann äh ist ja die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß, dass sich da äh also wir haben eigentlich ja jetzt schon von euch gibt's eine ausführliche Analyse. Ähm es gibt viele Leute, die sich da jetzt schon zu äußern. Äh es
kann ja davon auszugehen sein, dass eventuell auch äh in der, innerhalb der Regierung
dieser Entwurf plötzlich jemand in die Hände gerät, der sich darüber dann äh Gedanken macht,
Und äh da dann erkennt die Qualität dieses Entwurfes äh zu beurteilen in der Lage ist.
Und genau da darauf.
Darauf hoffen wir alle. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass dieser Entwurf den äh spätestens den parlamentarischen Prozess äh nicht überleben wird, äh weil er eben äh so viele Probleme ähm.
In sich trägt.
Äh aber natürlich ist die Hoffnung auch da, dass davor noch jemand sagt, ähm dieser Entwurf, äh um mit diesem Ansehen, dass hier überhaupt vertreten wird, äh das ist so gegen meine persönliche Richtung als Parlamentarier beispielsweise oder als Verantwortliche in einem Ministerium. Ähm wir können hier nur an die FDP denken beispielsweise
weil sie die hier entscheidenden Ministerien besetzt, äh wie zum Beispiel auch das Wirtschaftsministerium äh und dieser Entwurf ist äh eine Belastungsmaßnahme für die komplette Wirtschaft, wenn man diesen Aspekt mal herausgreift, weil er faktisch flächendeckend Rechtsunsicherheit
und 'ne Kostenpflicht einführt wenn die Unternehmen in diesem Bereich Presseschnipsel gewerblich nutzen wollen und das haben wir an sehr sehr vielen Stellen
eben passiert. Äh und äh dort müsste man schon eigentlich drauf setzen, dass äh dass einer der Verantwortlichen der FDP, Inselministerium äh dann auch sagt, okay ähm
das äh ist mit unseren Grundsätzen ja überhaupt nicht vereinbart. Wir wollen hier eigentlich nicht äh äh solche starken staatlichen Maßnahmen, die die Wirtschaft regulieren
sondern wir wollen hier eigentlich mehr Freiheit für die Wirtschaft und weniger Belastung, das Mantra übrigens, das immer vor sich hergetragen wird und dann kann man darauf hoffen, dass hier.
Die Vernunft wieder anfängt zu regieren, aber angesichts der Gesamtsituation und wir haben natürlich die FDP hier in der schwierigen politischen Lage, wenn man die gesamte.
Wenn ich da mal ganz kurz Zwischenfragen darf, ich erinnere mich an einen äh TV-Beitrag, ähm der er wurde dann auch irgendwie per YouTube da auf Netzpolitik org veröffentlicht, dass ähm.
Die FDP sich gegen das Leistungsschutzrecht gestellt hätte und zwar und gehe bei einem Parteitag. Und das hatte Jimmy Schulz dann sehr gefeiert.
Genau äh da gab's mehrere Entscheidungen. Das äh macht der macht die Situation äh noch interessanter. Äh der Landesverband äh der FDP in Bayern
und auch der Landesverband der FDP in Nordrhein-Westfalen, das sind die beiden
mächtigsten Landesverbände der Partei haben sich geschlossen gegen ein Leistungsschutzrecht gestellt
äh die zwei wichtigsten Landesverbände der Partei sind dagegen, ihre Minister äh treiben es trotzdem voran. Äh also innerparteilich äh würde ich mich äh als Mitglied des Landesverbandes Bayern oder Nordrhein-Westfalen
sehr fragen, was hier eigentlich gerade passiert. Äh und um vorher den Gedanken nochmal kurz zu Ende äh zu führen, äh die gesamt äh.
Mit der FDP. Wir haben hier natürlich genau auch die Machtverhältnisse ähm und die FDP ist in besonderem Maße auf das äh Goodwill der Presse angewiesen äh und ähm natürlich,
Politiker Angst
dass wenn in anderthalb Jahren der Bundestagswahlkampf ansteht und diejenigen, die die positive Berichterstattung eigentlich machen sollen und das sind insbesondere hier Burda und Springer und das sind die Haupt äh,
des Leistungsschutzrechtes, ähm dass die sagen, ja ihr wolltet uns äh hier das Leistungsschutzrecht nicht geben, ihr habt das verhindert
warum sollen wir euch dann im Wahlkampf unterstützen? Und das ist die klassische Angst der Politiker vor negativer Berichterstattung und das haben wir in einem ganz ganz starken Fall hier auch
es ist auch klar, dass
etliche relevante Politiker auch genau deswegen möglicherweise nicht ihren Überzeugungen folgen äh und das ist auch äh für eine Demokratie Problematisch.
Na ja, aber sagen wir mal ganz ehrlich, dann haben wir halt demnächst kein Google News mehr. Ähm das heißt, wir werden dann äh abgestraft werden. Ich glaube nicht ernst, ernsthaft, dass das dass es äh dass dass Google sich das gefallen lässt, ja.
Ähm aber lass uns erstmal, lass uns erstmal noch äh zwei, zwei Detailfragen, was was mir noch so ein bisschen ähm
am Herzen dieses
was ist mit diesem gewerblich äh ist das da jetzt irgendwie mal vernünftig drin ausdefiniert, weil es gab ja immer so noch diese offene Frage, was ist wenn ich äh Flatter auf meinem Blog habe, äh darf ich dann noch irgendwie oder nicht? Und ähm gab's da jetzt eine eine vernünftige Ausdefini
in diesem äh Gesetzesentwurf oder steht da nach wie vor einfach nur gewerblich drin und ähm es wird keinem weitergeholfen in der Frage.
Genau, die äh die Differenzierung findet statt zwischen privat und gewerblich
und privat fällt nicht runter, gewerblich schon gewerblich wird aber nicht näher definiert. Hier haben wir sozusagen den vollen Spielraum an Interpretationsmöglichkeiten. Es werden äh ein paar Beispiele genannt
in der Begründung was möglicherweise drunter fallen kann aber das ist komplett schwammig und reicht auch von vorne bis hinten nicht aus faktisch muss man sagen es ist komplett ungeklärt.
Gewerblich ist. Man muss davon ausgehen, äh dass äh auch der Flatterbutton im Prinzip reicht, äh wenn äh die Person ähm möglicherweise in Ausübung ihres Berufs ein privates Blog betreibt, beziehungsweise
sekundär mit diesem Blog auch
Werbung für den eigenen Beruf macht und dann diese Presseschnipsel verwendet. Also komplett ungeklärt äh was ähm dieser Begriff äh gewerblich eigentlich bedeuten soll.
Ja. Was äh.
Blödsinn.
Bitte? Ja, das äh gut. Ich meine, das war ja eigentlich immer immer absehbar, dass wenn überhaupt irgendeine Form vom Leistungsschutzrecht durchkommt, egal, wie sie jetzt genau definiert ist, dass das irgendwie zu Komplikationen führt, weil das macht einfach,
keinen Sinn, alles, also es ist äh alles ein bisschen äh Quatsch. Gut Philipp, vielen Dank.
Für die äh Erläuterung und äh wir werden das hier auch weiter begleiten äh wie es so weitergeht. Ich habe so den Eindruck, das könnte noch ein ganz lustiger Tanz werden.
Beste Lied noch nicht gesungen.
Lustig und spannend.
Okay, dann erstmal vielen Dank, ne. Tschüss.
Gerne, tschüss.
Ja so viel zum Leistungsschutzrecht. Das nächste Thema ist ja eigentlich ein Thema, was wir schon in der letzten Woche hätten.
Unterbringen können. Aber da habe ich mir ganz ehrlich gesagt äh gedacht, ähm.
So ein Quatsch, ähm das muss jetzt sich echt auch noch mit hochkochen. Es wurde dann aber zum, zum ganz großen Thema.
Der letzten Woche, nämlich,
Dass ähm Bekanntwerden eines Forschungsprojektes der Schufa in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Hasso Plattner Institut,
Ähm und die wollten überlegen, ob man nicht aus sozialen Netzwerken gewonnene Daten für die Aufgabe der Schufa nutzen kann, nämlich zur Ermittlung der Kreditwürdigkeit.
Mhm. Also es handelte sich dabei wirklich nur erstmal um eine Studie und nicht um konkrete Pläne.
Ja, also vielleicht noch kurz zur Erklärung, äh was was was ist die Schufa, ja? Die Schufa ist eine äh,
privatwirtschaftliche Auskunfts Wirtschaftsauskunft teil, heißt das nämlich, Auskunft Teil ähm und die wollen, da wollen sich die Unternehmen vor Kreditausfällen schützen,
und ähm die Schufa sagt, ja uns, sie schützt natürlich auch die Verbraucher äh vor der Überschuldung, ja, weil sie dafür sorgt, dass Leute, die nicht kreditwürdig sind, keinen Kredit kriegen und dann können sie sich nicht überschulden. Ja, es ist ein,
Dienst am Bürger, den die Schufa da äh.
Was ich sogar mit Einschränkungen für ein haltbares Argument äh halten würde, so auch wenn das vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt so im Mittelpunkt der Wahrnehmung steht.
Genau, also was machen sie? Sie sie schätzen die Kreditwürdigkeit ein, ja? Sie haben sie haben irgendwie ihre Mitglieder sammeln sehr, sehr viele Daten, haben irgendwie Versicherungen, Banken, Telefonanbieter, Vermieter,
Ähm und die liefern da so so ihre Sachen hin und sagen, ja, guck mal hier, zum Beispiel
bei mir steht dann bei der Schufa wahrscheinlich wo ich Bankkonten habe und wieder so die Latenzen sind ob ich ins Dispo komme oder nicht und ob ich da auch immer wieder rauskomme und vertragswidriges Verhalten wird dann eben
der Schufa gemeldet und dann wird gesagt, hier guck mal der Neumann, der hat irgendwie 'n,
dem wurde mal die Wohnung gekündigt, weil er, weil er drei Monate lang die Miete nicht gezahlt hat oder sowas, ja? Oder oder der fällt dadurch auf, dass ihm die Telekom alle drei Wochen irgendwie das Telefon wieder abstellen muss, weil er die paar hundert Euro Rechnung nicht bezahlen kann,
Haben Sie also so erheben irgendwie Selbstdaten, äh die Vertragspartner liefern da was hin? Der ZEK, äh die die schauen aber auch zum Beispiel in die Schuldnerverzeichnisse der Amtsgerichte.
Was ist ZDK? Na ja.
Ich wusste es, dass du fragen wirst. Und ich hab's äh gerade nicht mehr. Ja zentrale ähm.
Zentralstelle für Kreditinformationen. Genau, Zitze, Verein, zur Führung einer Zentralstelle für,
Kreditinformation. Ich wusste nicht mehr genau, wo das wo das E herkam, ja. Äh.
Woher kommt jetzt das E?
Die sammeln also alle diese Daten. Was was machen sie jetzt damit, ja? Ähm also ein ein wichtiger Hinweis noch, ähm man ähm,
Man kann sich dort einmal im Jahr nach ähm nach Paragraf vierunddreißig Bundesdatenschutzgesetz ähm,
eine Datenübersicht schicken lassen, was die,
von einem so haben, was sie da so sammeln. Und das äh zu machen ist gar nicht blöd, weil es sehr, sehr viele äh gebrannte Kinder gibt, wo dann irgendwelche
mal die falsche Person den Schuh vor Eintrag bekommen hat, ja? Oder wo er nicht mehr gelöscht wurde, obwohl ähm die Angelegenheit geklärt wurde, ja, also beispielsweise irgendwie ähm Gerichts äh Urteil oder eine äh so dann gezeigt hat, dass es kein,
sie nicht hätten zahlen müssen, ja?
Dann aber die Firmen natürlich äh oder die die Gläubiger natürlich das letzte, was die am am Tag machen, ist dann diesen Schuhvereintrag wieder rausnehmen. Da gibt's also größere Probleme, meint teilweise.
Wenn also spätestens wenn man irgendwann mal merkt, du hier die Kreditzinsen, die ich da angeboten bekomme äh oder warum kriege ich denn den Kredit nicht oder warum darf ich diesen Handyvertrag nicht abschließen? Spätestens dann sollte man sich das durchaus mal anschauen, was da bei der Stufe ist, weil das natürlich auch
ein bisschen Feder da da gibt. Aber.
Also, was macht die Schufa, hat diese ganzen Daten und äh sammelt die und hat dann einen einen Algorithmus, ähm wo sie diese Daten gewichten, ja? Das heißt, es gibt irgendwie sagen wir mal, okay, wenn jemand ähm,
einmal in in zehn Jahren seine Handyrechnung nicht bezahlt. Das das ist irgendwie nicht nichts Besonderes, wenn er das irgendwie aber schon bei allen Providern auf der schwarzen Liste steht. Das ist dann irgendwie was ernstzunehmenderes, ne? Oder ähm natürlich wollen sie aber auch nicht erst
ähm,
Die Aussage dann haben, wenn sie erkennen, da hat jemand nicht bezahlt, sondern die wollen die Aussage natürlich sehr viel früher machen können. Das heißt, sie wollen prognostizieren, dass ich demnächst nicht bezahle,
obwohl ähm eventuell ich das bisher immer gemacht habe. Ja, also dieser Schutz vor Überschuldung, ja? Also ich,
auf einmal mehr Geld und möchte dann äh mir den Porsche kaufen und dann kann die Schufa sagen.
Du mein Eindruck ist, laut unserer, laut unserem Algorithmus äh kann halt nicht gut gehen. So, das heißt, sie wollen prognostizieren, ob ich bezahle oder nicht,
Und diese Aussage kann's natürlich nur probabilistisch machen. Das heißt, sie haben diesen großen Datenpool ähm und gewichten, die einzelnen Informationsquellen so zusammen, dass sie
möglichst in ihrem Datenbestand, den sie ja haben, der ja auch über die Zeit verteilt ist, quasi immer den, den die Fortführung des Datenbestandes korrekt vorhersagen.
Und das dann natürlich.
Konstant anpassen, also diese die Gewichte der einzelnen Werte äh und ihre Verhältnisse zueinander. So was weiß ich äh Lottogewinn sticht äh äh Porsche nicht bezahlen können oder so, ja? Ähm.
Ist es mal einfacher, ich versuch's immer dann.
Ja ja.
Und was man dann natürlich, was,
Was man dann also am Ende hat, ist ein Scoringwert und den kriegen dann die kriegen die Mitglieder dann mitgeteilt und können sich dann entscheiden, ob sie, ob sie mit derjenigen Person einen Vertrag eingeht oder nicht. Und die geben natürlich dann auch wieder das Feedback.
Und dadurch kann sich dieses System immer wieder validieren und sagen, okay, da habe ich falsch gelegen, da muss ich meine Gewichtung wieder äh korrigieren. Eigentlich ganz schön. Ich habe sowas ja auch früher,
selber ganz gerne gemacht. Also so Datenanalyse. Und jetzt kommen die also auf die Idee und sagen, jetzt wollen wir,
ähm haben wir einen neuen Datenbestand, der da irgendwie so anfällt und das ist dieses Social Media Verhalten,
Und das ist äh sind öffentliche Daten. Das Schöne ist, die Schufa darf öffentliche Daten äh sich so zu Gemüte führen. Und also hat sie einfach gesagt, gut, dann machen wir mal ein Forschungsprojekt, ob wir da irgendwie auch was draus gewinnen können. Ähm,
Solche Daten sind nur dann interessant, wenn sie quasi eine Zusatzinformation haben, ja. Und das war auch das, was in dieser, was in der, in der, der Rezeption dann so schiefgegangen ist, weil dann irgendwie also da,
wirklich selten,
Dichte an an unsinnigen Artikeln zu diesem Thema. Wo dann also einer sagte, ja, wenn die Schufa äh aus Facebook.
Ähm das schafft die Kreditwidrigkeit vorherzusagen
dann ähm dann braucht man die Schufa nicht mehr, dann ist sie bald zu. Ja, also nee, darum geht's eben nicht. Es geht darum, dass sie einen minimalen Prozentpunkt besser eventuell werden könnten. Das würde ihnen ja schon reichen. Ja, wenn sie solche Daten berücksichtigen würden.
Andere, anderer Beitrag war die Schufa wird humaner
weil sie jetzt den Menschen anschaut und nicht mehr nur die Zahlen, also völlig völliger Irrsinn, äh völliger Quatsch. Also was was sie da machen wollen ist, äh sie könnten halt ihre ihre Genauigkeit vielleicht um ein paar Prozentpunkte verbessern, wenn sie in gewissen Fällen
bestimmte Auffälligkeiten im im Social Media Bereich ähm mitberücksichtigen würden.
Also ein paar Prozentpunkte wäre ja schon wirklich eine Menge. Hinter dem Komma, ja.
Hinterm Komma, hinterm Komma hinter dem Komma, aber das reicht. Ich meine, die haben die führen äh über sechsundsechzig Millionen Personen,
Ähm da Daten,
Wenn du jetzt überlegst, die kriegen Anfragen, ich weiß nicht wie viele tausende Anfragen die am Tag bekommen. Und wenn dann die Vorhersagequalität nur um um irgendwie paar Punkte hinterm Komma besser wird, sind das direkt.
Mehrere Fälle pro Tag, ja? Ähm zumal,
Dass er auch in beide Richtungen schiefgehen kann. Ja, also es könnte, es heißt ja nicht nur, dass die Schufa aufgrund deines äh Facebook-Verhaltens dann äh dir keine Kredite mehr gibt, sondern,
also sie wollen ja ihr System will ja so sein, dass es möglichst wenige und möglichst wenige Falls Negatives hat, weil wenn,
Mia als als Dienstanbieter rät, mit dir keinen Vertrag zu machen, du aber völlig einwandfrei in der Lage wärst, das alles zu bezahlen, dann ist das ja auch nicht zu meinem Vorteil,
Ja, also die müssen halt wirklich dann ihre Genauigkeit üben.
Da stehen sie dann wahrscheinlich auch entsprechend unter Druck, unter äh von den Anfragen der Unternehmen, ne?
Absolut, ja?
Weil die wollen ja auch Geld verdienen.
Und ähm also sie haben äh haben also auf jeden Fall ihre ähm ihre Probleme. Jetzt.
Wenn man so ein Modell macht mit so vielen Eingangsinformationen, ist die Frage, man spricht da von Orthogonalität eigentlich. Du möchtest.
Unkorellierte Merkmale haben. Und das ist auch das Interessante bei der bei dieser bei dieser Social Media Sache, warum die da wahrscheinlich Interesse daran hatten, weil es ein ein unkorelliertes,
eine unkoordinierte Informationsquelle ist, ja? Also irgendwie Vertragsbrüche
äh Dispo überziehen, das ist alles das zieht so in eine Richtung ab, ja, da da bestätigt immer nur eins das andere, aber ich möchte quasi eine Dimension haben, die quer dazu liegt
um äh überhaupt noch Informationsgewinn haben zu können. Und deswegen hatten die daran Interesse. Ähm andererseits muss man auch einfach mal überlegen, es gibt halt auch,
Einfach Merkmale, die mit der Zielgröße in dem Fall Kreditwürdigkeit vielleicht einfach nicht in Zusammenhang stehen. Das hätten die mit diesem Forschungsprojekt rausfinden können,
hätten sie wahrscheinlich auch. Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie nach
nachhaltig ihre Vorhersagequalität hätten verbessern können aufgrund irgendwelcher äh Daten, die sie in Social Networks generieren, ja. Ähm.
Was soll's sein? Ich meine.
Unkorreliertes Merkmal Punkt hat damit nichts zu tun. Danke, nicht signifikanter Beitrag zum zur Modell und.
Ja gut, die eigentliche Frage ist, gibt's äh überhaupt irgendeine nachvollziehbare Vision? Wie jetzt diese äh Analyse hätte helfen können,
Man muss ja da überhaupt erstmal einen Bezug zu der realen Person äh herstellen, wenn da jetzt irgendwie Peter äh äh Schmidt und Thomas Müller da äh irgendwie auf Facebook posten, dann weiß er auch erstmal nicht, wer das ist. Ähm.
Deswegen ja Forschungsprojekt, ja.
Ja, ja, okay, also es ist insofern auch erstmal gar nichts Schlimmes, weil man hätte ja mal forschen können, weil die Forschung ist ja auch nun mal Forschung.
Forschung ist gut, Forschung hat am Ende ein Ergebnis, so werden wir es nie wissen und müssen uns jetzt mit diesen Artikeln rumschlagen.
Genau, weil sich ja äh das Hassel Plattner Institut dann äh.
Sofort am nächsten Tag ähm hat es Hasso Plattner Institut diese Zusammenarbeit gecancelt. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage.
Ich, wie gesagt, komme ja oder habe eine Vergangenheit in der Forschung. Bin deswegen gegen natürlich dieser Sache aufgeschlossen, weil ich's modellierungsmäßig interessant finde.
Aus bürgerrechtlicher Datenschutzrechtlicher, ethischer Überlegung, muss man sich natürlich schon fragen, ob man möchte.
Dass es eine solche Institution gibt, die mit nicht offengelegten ähm Algorithmen,
Entscheidungen trifft, die zu überprüfen, ähm eigentlich niemand in der Lage ist, ja? Also die trifft eine Tatsachenentscheidung so und so kriegt keinen Kredit mehr und das wird gemacht. Keiner hat keiner zweifelt an der Schufa.
Es gibt auch niemanden, der im Prinzip ihre Vorhersagequalität ernsthaft nochmal validieren kann, außer ihnen selbst,
Und selbst da ist natürlich der Fall, wenn die Schufa, wer schlechte Schuhfahrt, kriegt keinen Kredit mehr. Der kann nicht das Gegenteil beweisen.
Kommen also an einen Punkt, an dem sie sich einfach immer nur selber
bestätigen. Und deshalb fand ich, was dann sehr schön gesagt wurde von Markus Beckedal in der,
Pressemitteilung von digitale Gesellschaft. Wir sind besorgt, äh dass hier Unfug getrieben wird. Es wäre also an der Zeit, dass die Schufa ihre Algorithmen offenlicht, vielleicht versteckt sich daran ja bereits ähnlicher Unfug.
Also fand ich sehr, sehr schön, dass mal das mal so zu betrachten, weil also wie gesagt, forschungsmäßig interessanter Punkt äh in Bezug auf ähm,
ob man eine solche Institution komplett privatwirtschaftlich geführt ähm, undurchsichtig steckt ihre Nase überall rein, hat Algorithmen die also rein von der wissenschaftlichen Überlegungen, von theoretischen Überlegungen her,
schwierig äh es schwierig haben, sich selber zu widerlegen, weil sie können sich nur in dem Fall widerlegen, dass sie Kreditwürdigkeit einräumen,
aber äh diese dann nicht bestanden hat, dann wird man's halt merken,
Aber wenn sie Kreditwürdigkeit nicht einräumen und diese aber trotzdem besteht, dieser Fall, da werden sie viel, viel schlechter widerlegt. Das ist also in dem Modell inhärent.
Und ähm das heißt also ja, die die Debatte, ob die Schufa da rein,
darf und was das für unsere Welt bedeutet, die war durchaus mal eine oder für unsere Gesellschaft bedeutet, die war dann durchaus ganz interessant.
Ähm aber was was die was die fachliche oder die inhaltliche Überlegung Erregung anging, war diese Debatte eher ähm
etwas traurig. So, das Forschungsprojekt wurde eingestellt, das Hasso-Plattner Institut hat ähm eine etwas säuerliche Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, in der er dann gesagt wurde, na ja, äh das wäre ja jetzt mal echt interessante
ähm eine interessante Forschung gewesen, aber äh mit wenn wenn hier in der in den Medien so darüber berichtet wird, dann können wir das hier nicht in Ruhe machen.
Das ist auch nachvollziehbar in gewisser Hinsicht, ne. War ich mal so mit so einem Level an an kritischer, also äh kritischer Begleitung ist äh nie ein Fehler, aber ist äh auch dann,
damit zu rechnen, dass wir eine sehr unkritische Begleitung haben oder eine überkritische Begleitung haben. Das macht dann wahrscheinlich auch keinen Spaß.
Also Fazit, ich,
was ich jetzt so dazu gesagt habe, ich glaube, dass validere Schufa Ergebnisse kaum zu erwarten gewesen wären, weil ich davon ausgehe, dass da die die Zusammenhänge eigentlich nicht äh herzustellen sind, beziehungsweise nicht bestehen. Ähm.
Ja. Ähm.
Und damit werden die Ergebnisse auch nicht nennenswert falscher als heute. Und ähm die Frage, wie man dazu stehen möchte, dass.
Daten, die öffentlich sind von Menschen genutzt werden, ähm ja, die muss man sich eben an anderer Stelle stellen, ne? Weil ich die Schufa darf das auf jeden Fall. Es gibt gesetzlich hier ähm überhaupt gar keine.
Keine Schwierigkeiten in dieser in dieser Frage. Schufa hatte ausdrückliche Recht dazu, sich öffentliche Daten anzueignen.
Ja, trotzdem dürft ihr die Schufa auch mal wieder ein weiteres Mal gemerkt haben, dass sie mit ihrer ganzen Aktivität schon einer kritischen Öffentlichkeit ausgesetzt ist und das ist ja auch gut so.
Absolut, also äh sehr viel Kritik an diesem Ansatz da und wenn man sich einfach nur mal so anschaut so SCUFA-Opfer, äh da da findet man wirklich die wildesten Sachen, ne. Du kämpfst dann dagegen so eine ähm,
Behördenartig äh strukturierte eiserne Kette,
die die dir einfach dann wirklich die Teilhabe am Leben versaut, weil weil irgendein Idiot den falschen Schuhverein gemacht hat.
Alternative ist, ne?
Ja äh also die Alternative, wenn ich jetzt mal etwas ketzerisch sagen darf, ist ja,
haben wir ja vor ein paar Jahren in den USA gesehen, als man sich gegen ähm dagegen entschieden hat, auf ähm gerade bei der bei der Vergabe von äh Immobilienkrediten
auf die Wirtschaftsauskunft Haien zu hören, ja? Und ähm zack, los geht's!
Schon hat man die dicke Immobilienblase an der Backe, weil alle kriegen hier irgendwie einen Kredit und Hauptsache Hauptsache, das System wird weiter gefüttert und äh bläst sich damit selber auf,
Gewinne und am Ende ist klar, irgendwann
Pyramidenmodell geht's dann irgendwann einfach in die Rose, weil nicht mehr genug nachkommt, was noch in der Lage ist, da irgendwie Geld reinzuschieben.
Dann merkt man das gar kein Star ist. Ja, kann schon sein. Gut. Sehr viel mehr können wir dazu jetzt nicht sagen, oder?
Wie einer von Sack, weil ich irgendwie zu sich überhaupt gesagt habe, dass solche Datenanalysen eventuell sinnvoll sein können. Äh sind sie aber halt nicht. Also in dem Fall sind sie es nicht, aber als Forscher muss ich sagen, wir hätten eine Antwort auf die Frage bekommen und die kriegen wir jetzt nicht.
Als Forscher.
Es wäre doch wunderschön gewesen, wenn die Schufa da so ein paar Millionen in Potsdam am HPI versenkt, ja und am Ende kommt raus, ja Social Network könnt ihr vergessen. Ja. Hm, hör doch auf, hör doch auf, was Nettes.
Ja, dass wir auch was Nettes gewesen. Jetzt müssen wir die Millionen woanders versenken. Kommen wir zu den äh guten Nachrichten der Woche.
Ja, wir bleiben bei den öffentlichen Daten. Also auch hier, die Schufa wird jetzt bald in Hamburg zuschlagen, denn das Transparenzgesetz.
Ähm hat die Hamburger nicht das Transparent doch also wie würde man sagen, die das die Hamburger Bürgerschaft hat das Transparenzgesetz angenommen.
Genau, das Transparenzgesetz, darüber haben wir hier auch schon mal berichtet, beziehungsweise berichten lassen. Das ist im Rahmen unserer neunten Sendung, die äh Interviewserie
wir da gemacht haben auf dem achtundzwanzigsten Chaos Kongress, ganz konkret haben wir da mit Dodja gesprochen aus Hamburg vom CCC Hamburg, der,
einer derjenigen waren, die da sehr maßgeblich ähm mitgearbeitet haben, dieses Transparenzgesetz überhaupt erstmal zu entwickeln, beziehungsweise auch die entsprechende
Initiative Transparenz schafft Vertrauen da voranzutreiben, die ähm.
Noch dabei war, Transparency International und der Verein mehr Demokratie.
Genau, wollte ich auch gerade sagen. Also es war jetzt nicht nur eine Aktivität vom CCC, sondern sehr äh übergreifende Aktivität. Ich glaube, die Piraten haben da auch noch mal ein bisschen reingegrätscht. Also auf jeden Fall äh ist es erstaunlich, dass das Ganze auch in Hamburg jetzt so positiv angenommen worden
ist und jetzt wohl von der Bürgerschaft auch beschlossen worden. Also der Beschluss ist jetzt durch, ne?
Sollte am Mittwoch durchgegangen sein, ja. Also äh ich habe keinen Aufschrei gehört, also es war, wir hatten das wurde dann so, es wird heute beschlossen werden.
War dann überschlugen sich dann schon äh die die Nachrichten. Ähm,
Um das noch kurz zusammenzufassen, wie gesagt, wir haben da ein sehr gutes Gespräch mit deutscher in der äh LNP neun ähm und konkret geht's darum, dass Senatsbeschlüsse, Gutachten, Verträge, Baugenehmigungen, Daten, alle möglichen Dokumente, Statistiken, Verträge vor allem
und Vorschriften strukturiert Maschinen lesbar zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Hatte sein,
Ursprung, das Interesse daran, insbesondere was die Verträge betrifft, ähm in der,
Problem mit der Elbphilharmonie, die sich da in Hamburg ja aufgetan haben, wo etwas im Prinzip kostenneutral entstehen sollte und am Ende irgendwie,
dann doch nicht ganz so kostenneutral war. Und was äh wo sich jetzt eigentlich viele die Hände reiben, dieses Gesetz als in Hamburg beschlossenes, existentes Gesetz, kann natürlich jetzt sehr gut als Blaupause dienen, auch für andere Bundesländer.
Das heißt, da werden wir hoffentlich ähm eine sehr große ähm Welle an Nachahmern jetzt sehen,
und damit eine sehr große äh Open Data Initiative in den ähm einzelnen Bundesländern.
Ja, das wird spannend. Bin echt äh echt gespannt, was was dabei rauskommt.
Also nochmal ganz großen, herzlichen Glückwunsch an alle,
sich dort beteiligt habenden. Und es ging ja sogar ohne den Bürgerentscheid, ne? Das war also die das wäre ja noch die
die Option die Gefahr gewesen, dass dass ihnen das um um die Ohren gewatscht wird und sie dann irgendwie ich glaub irgendwas fast siebzig, achtzigtausend Unterschriften gebraucht hätten innerhalb einer kurzen Zeit. Das hatte Dodja uns ja noch erzählt, dass sie im Prinzip damit,
Diese Gefahr irgendwie sehen müssen. Aber einfach durchgekommen. Sie haben's eingesehen.
Super. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. So, was haben wir als nächstes? Äh.
Facebook war in der Tagesschau. Wirklich. Facebook war in der Tagesschau, ja. Äh.
Wirklich? Das ist ja interessant, dass das Thema jetzt so viel oder meinst du, die Webtageschau? Die gibt's ja.
Nee, das war tagesschau oder Tagesthemen oder so. Ähm weil sie mal wieder ihre Datenschutzregeln äh zu Gunsten der ökonomischen äh Datenauswertung verbessert haben. Ähm,
und was sie da gemacht haben war eigentlich ganz schön. Sie haben nicht gesagt, ja ähm die Nutzer haben die Möglichkeit ähm zur zur Gegenabstimmung, weil es gab irgendwie über siebentausend Beschwerden.
Ähm gegen diese neuen Datenschutzbestimmungen und die sogar die Facebook Regeln sehen dann vor, dann, dann gibt's eine Abstimmung,
Kein Problem, Freunde. Also, machen wir eine Abstimmung. Und,
Diese Abstimmung hat dann ein von dreißig Prozent. Das heißt, dreißig Prozent der Facebooker ähm müssen sich an der Abstimmung beteiligen, damit das Ergebnis Relevanz hat, ja? Also ist ja beim.
Müssen sie sich beteiligen oder müssen auch dagegen stimmen?
Müssen sich beteiligen erstmal damit, damit man sagt, okay, dann.
Genau, so ein Quorum, wie man das bei einer bei einem Bürger äh Bürgerentscheid oder sowas natürlich auch hat, ne. Also es müssen erstmal genug hingehen, damit du damit du damit du überhaupt das Ergebnis anerkennst.
So und äh bei dieser äh,
Bei dieser Sache, also dreißig Prozent werden nach aktuellen Zahlen so schlappe zweihundertsiebzig Millionen Menschen gewesen, die sich daran hätten beteiligen müssen,
und äh diese Abstimmung hatte Facebook aber jetzt natürlich auch nicht irgendwie auf Seite eins, ja? Weil ähm Facebook natürlich jetzt nicht unbedingt das Interesse hat, ähm.
Die die Abstimmung jetzt irgendwie zu promoten, weil ja klar ist, wer daran teilnimmt, ist Gegner, waren dann auch irgendwie äh achtzig, neunzig Prozent waren dagegen. Dreihundertfünfzigtausend Leute haben am Ende teilgenommen, also ein müder Furz in der Prärie, ähm aber,
die äh.
Aber es ist halt.
Aber es ist halt, was ich ganz schön finde, ist, man, wenn man sich das mal anschaut, ähm also man erkennt da, was das bedeutet, wenn eben so ein Unternehmen die Infrastruktur für die eigene für die eigene Abstimmung ist, ja? Also.
Sie konnten ja quasi entscheiden, wo sie diese Abstimmung platzieren und wie sie die formulieren und was nicht alles. Und selbstverständlich hauen sie den nicht auf Seite eins. Aber wenn,
wenn das gesamte Ökosystem in dieser Form bestimmt wird, ja, also wenn in in einer in einer Demokratie, wenn ich jetzt sage, okay, hier ähm.
Ich mache jetzt hier eine Bürgerinitiative und arbeite auf einen Volksentscheid hin, ähm dann ist es auch nicht so, dass sich, dass sich die Regierung irgendwie besonders anstrengt,
ähm meinen, was weiß ich, meinen Spreeufer, Volksentscheid äh oder meinen Tempelhof äh so und so äh weiterverwendungsfolgsentscheid irgendwie,
zu promoten, wenn es gegen ihre eigene Politik steht. Aber ich habe wenigstens noch Möglichkeiten, das irgendwie zu machen,
innerhalb von Facebook dann da also man sieht einfach dass sie es nicht geschafft haben und letztendlich im Zweifelsfall ist natürlich schon.
Nicht unbedingt im Interesse äh der Nutzer ist, ja.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, was sie hatten. Die äh Pläne lagen doch äh mehrere Wochen. Nur wenige, nur wenige Lichtjahre von ihrem Planeten entfernt. Äh öffentlich aus.
Ich äh wollte noch ganz kurz, ich hatte letztens noch so so einen Datenzusammenführungsmoment, den ich noch erzählen wollte, ganz kurz, ich hatte mal ganz, ganz früher einen Blog bei,
Äh bei Blogger dot com. Und irgendwann wurde Blogger dot com mit Google zusammengeführt und irgendwie ähm hatte ich dann vor zehn Jahren da irgendwie ein Bild äh geblockt, was hm was ich jetzt irgendwie entfernt haben wollte.
Ähm und schaute also so,
irgendwie wie wie kriege ich jetzt dieses Bild weg? Ja und dann schaute ich irgendwie bei Blogger und merkte dann irgendwie.
Dass diese Daten, dieses Bild, was ich da irgendwann vor zehn, na, zehn Jahre waren's nicht, aber vor acht Jahren oder sechs Jahren in dieses Blog da geladen habe. Das war inzwischen,
in einer Picasa äh in einem Picasa Fotoalbum in meinem Google Plus.
So viel zu zu dieser Dienstezusammenführung. Ich meine, ich fand's ganz schön, weil das hat mir eine angenehme Oberfläche dazu geboten, ähm diese Sache zu löschen,
Aber ähm also Dienstezusammenführung ahoi, ja, vor ein paar Jahren irgendwo mal irgend so ein Schnappschuss äh in Blogger geladen und inzwischen ist es ein Picasa Fotoalbum. War ich sehr überrascht, weil ich gar nicht wusste, dass ich Picasa Foto-Alben hatte. Ich war,
wusste gar nicht, dass ich Picassa Kunde bin, bin ich aber jetzt.
Jetzt nicht mehr, aber ähm war ich war ich unwissentlich. Ja, also ganz ganz interessant wieder ähm diese diese Dienstezusammenführung bei Google,
Okay, so viel dazu.
Wollen wir mal den äh internationalen Aktivismus hier aufm Plan.
Aber jetzt, jetzt, jetzt äh kommen Sie nun zum internationalen Teil der Gala. Äh wir holen unseren nächsten Gast mit hinzu.
Genau, beziehungsweise müsste er sich mal kurz selber äh dazu holen. Äh Thomas.
Hallo? Hallo, hallo, grüße euch. Ah, morgen, ihr Morgen.
Bekannt den Hörern, glaube ich, ne, von ähm der Sendung mit dem Titel Cordoba zwei Punkt null.
Genau, aus Funk und Fernsehen.
Und macht jetzt auch selber das, was man vielleicht auch erstmal pluggen, äh macht auch selber äh Netzpolitik-Podcast jetzt, und zwar die Netzkinder AT.
Ja, ganz genau. Äh vielen Dank für den Plug. Ähm ist ist noch so ein kleines Projekt, aber entwickelt sich schon recht gut
und nicht nur im Podcast, sondern auch im Blog. Also wir versuchen da
generell so ein bisschen Plattform zu sein, für alles Mögliche, was so in Netzpolitik und Netzkultur in Österreich passiert. Also alle, die das interessiert, können sich das gerne anschauen.
Äh ja, vielleicht auch noch, ich habe noch einen Nachtrag, diese Facebook Geschichte, das war Max Shrems, der diese Abstimmung angerissen hat.
Von versus Facebook die Leute.
Ganz genau, ja. Das ist auch.
Äh muss man immer wieder rausstreichen, weil der ist in Wirklichkeit alleine mit allem, was er tut und stemmt trotzdem irgendwie wahnsinnig viel, wenn's wenn's drum geht so Facebook-Sachen aufzuzeigen. Der hat sich auch mal mit Videoüberwachung rund ums Parlament beschäftigt und der ist irgendwie so ein One-Man RMI.
Ja.
Ja, dann äh hier noch mal äh herzliches Beileid äh na ich also es ist halt er kämpft da halt wirklich als als David gegen Goliath, ne? Und hat leider noch nicht die die,
gefunden oder oder die Schleuder, um um diesen Goliath wirklich mal eins auszuwischen. War ja, glaube ich, zwischenzeitlich diesen diesen Erfolg hatte mit dem Extrahieren der Daten, ne? Ich meine, wie kriege ich meine Daten von Facebook?
Genau und damit hat er halt zumindest enorme Medienöffentlichkeit
erlangt. Also ich glaube bis zu Alt-Jasierra, den haben wirklich äh alle möglichen internationalen Medien interviewt. Und das hat zumindest mal Bewusstsein geschaffen, dass dieses Unternehmen sich jetzt nicht unbedingt einem Mitte zwanzig Wiener Justudenten unterwerfen wird, ist auch klar.
Ja
Ja äh was so die internationale Aktivität äh betrifft, ähm gab's ja auch äh eine weitere.
Akte Aktionstag.
Genau, letzten Samstag war's mal wieder soweit, das zweite Mal. Beim ersten Mal waren wir ja noch sehr äh überrascht über die große Beteiligung.
Ja
Dieses Mal muss ich zu meiner Schande gestehen, hatte ich leider keine Gelegenheit äh zu großen Beteiligungen selbst beizutragen. Wart ihr vor Ort?
Soll ich erstmal von Berlin erzählen? Ähm wir hatten.
Ähm für die Berliner Demo, weil das beim letzten Mal ja so so schön war und so viele, so viele tausend Leute da waren, äh hatten wir auf jeden Fall gesagt, okay, wir brauchen eine größere Anlage und ähm es wurde,
Es wurde dann auch nicht gekleckert, ja? Und zwar ähm wurde organisiert eine,
Das ist einfach so die Referenzklasse der Anlage. Das ist das, was was halt, wenn da, wenn irgendwo eine ernstzunehmende Anlage steht, dann ist das eine. Zum Beispiel im Berghain,
So, diese Anlage hatten wir oder ein also daraus diese Komponenten hatten wir oft auf diesem LKW äh drei Basswürfel und drei äh Satelliten oben drauf. Ähm wunderschönes Ding.
Lief schön Techno-Mucke,
Und äh wir fuhren dann irgendwie los und als wir dann so durch Friedrichshain fuhren, äh gegenüber die Autoalarmanlagen an, weil die Anlage ein bisschen zu laut war. Also.
Ich habe den Tweet von dir gelesen auf unserer Demo. Da wirklich sehr ela.
Ich würde es wirklich als also in meinen Augen, was ein voller Erfolg. Ähm leider waren aber wahrscheinlich nur etwas über fünfhundert Leute da,
Und die hatten jetzt, sage ich mal, nicht so diesen hedonistischen Demoansatz, sondern ähm haben sich dann auch tatsächlich äh vereinzelt beschwert, dass sie jetzt keine äh Parolen skandieren konnten.
Wegen der Musik.
Ja gut, das ging nicht, ne? Also entweder Musik oder.
Also, die Anlage war schon wirklich, ich ich habe, ich fand's göttlich. Aber es war in dem Fall dann wirklich ähm.
Produktiv.
Ja, vielleicht nicht kontraproduktiv, aber sagen wir mal, man hätte mit dem mit diesem Schweinegeld, was was dafür ausgegeben wurde, vielleicht wirklich eine,
Bei einer anderen Gruppe protestierender äh sehr viel mehr äh Wertschätzung dieses einmaligen Gerätes ähm,
erreichen können, ja? Die Demo, wie gesagt, war mit fünfhundert Leuten ähm ganz okay besucht. Ähm.
Nahm dann so ihren Lauf. Ähm am Ende haben gesprochen, also zu Beginn hat MS Pro eine sehr schöne Rede, äh wieder das Urheberrecht gehalten. Der entwickelt sich noch zum zum soulitischen Agitator, also sehr gut, weil das erste Mal, dass er.
Ja, nee, er hat wirklich eine gute Rede gehalten. Das ist wirklich gut. Und ähm,
War auch seine erste und kann ich nur sagen, mehr davon. Ähm und dann nachher sprachen noch, ja, Markus Becker, da sprach natürlich und,
Anna Thor Stefanovic über den Bereich der äh Wissenschaften und Peter Sunde war da Peter Sohn, der war da und sprach ähm auch kurz zum Thema.
Petersunde von äh.
Pirate und Flater, je nachdem.
Zeitraum mein betrachtet. Mhm.
Und äh so war es dann insgesamt doch ein ein ganz netter Tag mit natürlich einer sehr
schwachen Beteiligung und das liegt, denke ich, sehr eindeutig an dieser ins Leere laufen lassen, Strategie, ja, ja, acta macht euch mal keine Sorgen und auf die lange Bank geschoben und so weiter
Ähm also die Strategie ist da eindeutig aufgegangen.
Ist das auch in Wien so gewesen, Thomas.
Sehr ähnlich. Also wir hatten nur noch in Wien eine Demo, nicht mehr in den anderen Städten und hier in Wien waren's auch nur knapp vierhundert Leute
Also definitiv kleiner, wir hatten auch Regen von der Hälfte der Demo weg. Hm das war sicherlich auch irgendwie ein Faktor. Aber es war halt trotzdem wieder kreativ. Also das das hat sie ein bisschen gerettet. Ich sage nur, Akta macht nackter.
Yeah. Da müssen wir direkt mal noch das Bild.
War das jetzt nur ein Slogan oder gab's da auch äh entsprechende.
Nee, nee, nee, das war schon auch so mit ähm ja, so so diese Gruppe Zeit, äh die hat sich da in Schale geworfen.
Beziehungsweise entschalt. Mhm.
Ja, wobei sie hatten dann wirklich nette Schilder ähm auf äh gewissen Körperregionen.
Ah ja.
Wir suchen das Bild raus, das schicke ich euch noch.
Ich hab's ähm gefunden.
Es war lustig, weil das hat's dann gleich in die Future Zone geschafft irgendwie,
Ah ja.
Und ansonsten ähm ähm wir haben wirklich noch Politiker, die sich für Akte äußern, also unsere Justizministerin Beatrix Karl, die hat gemeint, na ja, irgendwie so schlimm ist das nicht.
Das ist ja eigentlich eh schon alles Gesetz in Österreich, da wird sich ja nichts ändern.
Und ähm das heißt, das ist irgendwie offiziell ist die Regierung zwar auch auf Abwarten, aber es gibt immer noch einzelne Stimmen, gerade die, die sehr nah an der Uhr bei Rechtsindustrie sind, die sagen das auch immer noch, dass das eigentlich eine gute Sache wäre.
Hm. Tja, wo sind denn dann die ganzen ähm
Also wie war denn so die die äh Altersstruktur? Ich meine bei der letzten Akta Demo waren ja wirklich verdammt viele äh junge Leute dabei, die so alle den Eindruck machten, das wäre jetzt mal so der erste netzpolitische,
Schub, den sie da bekommen hätten.
Ähm andere Leute haben gemeint, es sind viele Junge dort gewesen. Das
ich nicht so gesehen. Also es war eigentlich sehr gemischt. Es war nicht zu viele Masken wie sonst. Normalerweise sind das doch irgendwie ist das der der größte Teil der Demonstranten hat eine Maske auf. Das war diesmal nicht so.
Das kann auch ein gutes Zeichen sein.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Glaube ich auch langsam ein bisschen ab.
Also was ähm eventuell auch noch so als als Grund diskutiert, wobei ich ja wirklich der Theorieanhänger, dass es diese Inhalte und ins Leere laufen, Taktik der der entscheidende Faktor ist, ähm.
Es gab ja zu kurz vor der letzten Demo eben sehr äh so dieses enormes Video, was dann sehr, sehr,
Plakativ war,
Und äh sehr viel dreiundzwanzig Style hatte und ähm eventuell hat das dann halt auch noch mehr Menschen.
Mobilisiert, weil da eben einfach mal der der Teufel an die Wand gemalt wurde
Während Sicherheit dann im weiteren Diskussionsprozess um Akta eben doch diesen diese schwere Greifbarkeit ähm das auf die lange Bank schieben,
ähm einfach als äh als eine sehr gute Strategie erweist,
um da halt den Zorn nicht weiter stärker aufbranden zu lassen, ja?
Ja, ich sah halt so aus, als hätten wir schon gewonnen auf der einen Seite. Aber wirst du sagen uns sind die Verschwörungstheoretiker abhanden gekommen, weil wir keine ähm dramatischen Videos mehr hatten davor.
Nee, das so würde ich's nicht sagen, aber äh ich ich denke einfach, dass die die aktuelle ActA Situation hat
oder die aktuelle politische Situation eignete sich jetzt nicht unbedingt um noch einmal hunderttausende auf die Straßen zu bekommen
weil es gab einfach grade keinen, keinen akuten Anlass, ähm die offizielle äh das offizielle Narrativ war, das ist eh schon tot. Und ähm es eignete sich jetzt einfach nicht so zur zur Massenmobilisierung.
Ja, glaube ich auch. Aber wir werden's jetzt eh sehen. Ich glaube, Anfang Juli ist die Abstimmung im Europaparlament und da müssten wir es wissen.
Ja und dann werden wir uns die Augen reiben. Ich bin ja mal sehr gespannt. Also ich kriege ja immer äh frische Zahlen quasi aus Brüssel, was den, was den Stand angeht und im Moment ist es so bei fünfundvierzig Prozent. Ähm,
Ablehnung. Und das ist äh zu wenig.
Ja, wollen wir mal vielleicht den äh anderen Aspekt ähm aus Österreich besprechen. Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, äh was gibt's denn da Neues?
Ja, ich habe Updates für euch. Ähm bei der letzten Sendung habe ich ja noch angekündigt, dass wir auch eine Verfassungsklage einreichen wollen
Und SW Speed genau in diesem Moment der Aufnahme tragen wir die in den Verfassungsgerichtshof. Ähm die Kampagne ist beendet, die Klage ist fertiggeschrieben, revidiert,
und äh hat den Segen von allen Anwälten, die drübergeschaut haben. Und wir haben für diese Verfassungsgabe gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Österreich,
elftausendeinhundertneununddreißig Vollmachten,
elftausendeinhundertneununddreißig Menschen haben irgendwie ein Formular, Verfassungsklage RT ausgefüllt, unterschrieben in ein Kuvert gesteckt und uns geschickt.
Das ist ja wahnsinnig viel, weil die Hürde war diesmal weitaus größer als noch bei dieser Online-Bürgerinitiative,
und ja, elftausend, das ist definitiv die größte Verfassungsgabe, die es in Österreich jemals gegeben hat.
Und ja, jetzt sind die eben wahrscheinlich gerade so äh direkt im Verfassungsgerichtshof, weil um zehn hat's angefangen, jetzt ist gerade elf.
Und äh ja, im Grunde heißt jetzt dann Ivaten, also jetzt gibt's noch irgendwie so kurzen Medienevent, aber da muss der Gerichtshof arbeiten und das,
Natürlich mal. Wahrscheinlich Jahre, bis wir da eine Entscheidung haben,
Vielleicht das Erste, was ich äh da abzeichnen wird, ist, ob sich der Gerichtshof überhaupt mit dieser Klage beschäftigt,
wir gehen ja auch direkt zum Verfassungsgerichtshof und äh nicht über irgendeinen Instanzenzug von unten nach oben. Und da ist die die Tür, die man direkt zum Verfassungsgerichtshof gehen kann als normaler Bürger in Österreich, immer ziemlich schmal.
Aber wir wir haben das so hinbekommen, hoffentlich, dass wir genau da reinpassen in die Kriterien. Und im Grunde,
so die drei möglichen Ergebnisse, die wir uns erhoffen, wenn er sich mal entschieden hat, dass er diese Klage annimmt,
im Grunde müsste er dann eigentlich schon der einen oder anderen Form in unserem Sinne entscheiden, weil halt die Kritikpunkte so eklatant sind,
ähm und entweder wir haben halt diese Aufhebung des Gesetzes in Österreich, das wäre sozusagen ähm die Situation, die ihr in Deutschland hattet, dass das Gesetz zwar aufgehoben wird, aber man danach nochmal implementieren kann und noch einen Anlauf nehmen kann.
Die zweite Möglichkeit wäre, dass man prinzipiell sagt, so diese Richtlinie ist nicht verfassungskonform, das geht gar nicht. Und dann hätten wir die spannende Situation, dass
Brüssel zwar sagen kann, äh ihr müsst das umsetzen und äh wir drohen eure Strafzahlungen an. Und äh andererseits kann dann das eine nationale Parlament in die Regierung das nicht, weil eigentlich der Verfassungsgerichtshof das,
eben verboten hat schon. Das ist sicherlich die unwahrscheinlichste Variante, weil unser Verfassungsgerichtshof nicht so mutig ist und vor allem,
sich gegen EU-Entscheidungen zu stellen, das wäre total neu, das hätte er so noch nie gemacht. Und die wahrscheinlichste Variante leider und die, ja, aber auch nicht unbedingt Schlechteste wäre,
wenn er es einfach einer Prüfung vorm EuGH vorliegt. Also sozusagen einfach nochmal sagt so, äh ist diese Richtlinie überhaupt ähm,
verfassungskonform im Sinne von dieser dieser EU Grundrechte Charta,
Wir berufen uns ja auch teilweise auf dieser Grundrechte, Theater, die aus der Europäischen Union kommt und mit dem Vertrag von Lissabon eben in unsere Verfassung reingewandert ist, aber auch in vieler Verfassungen. Und dass wir auch spannend, weil damit könnte man auch die Richtlinie selbst
durch den EuGH kippen. Theoretisch zumindest.
Ja, das wäre schön, wenn das mal jemanden machen würde. Wir hatten ja leider die Meldung, dass das ihr, dass äh sich die die,
Idee, dass Irland äh sich in die Richtung anstrengen würde eventuell eine falsche war,
Also schauen wir mal, ich denke bei der Menge an Unterzeichnung solltet ihr äh keine Probleme haben, dass diese Verfassungsklage angenommen wird, ne. Also das äh kann ich mir schwer vorstellen. Wenn, dann gibt's irgendwie eine.
Unterstreichen mit diesen Vollmachten eigentlich nur dieses Argument der Streubreite der Maßnahme. Also wir wollen nicht, dass du irgendwie ähm den Verfassungsgerichtshof, der soll sich eigentlich nicht beeindrucken lassen durch die Menge an an Klägern, weil also
rein juristisch gesehen, musste einfach nach formalen.
Egal, ja, reicht ein.
Es ist natürlich einerseits ein politisches Symbol und es unterstreicht, dass da halt wirklich äh große Bevölkerungsteile und auch eben viele Organisationen und, und, und, und Kammern in Österreich dagegen sind, also
Ich glaube, das ist schon in die richtige Richtung gegangen. Wir haben sogar Ärztekammer, hat sich dem angeschlossen und äh Journalisten, Club und Journalisten, Gewerkschaft, also schon viele Gruppen mit Berufsgeheimnis und so und ich glaube eher, dass das in Österreich mehr wirkt als die große Zahl der Menschen.
Es sind halt irgendwie so ein Staat, der aufgebaut ist, auf lauter eingewachsenen Institutionen mit ganz viel Tradition. Count Car Monarie und so.
Wie viel ähm Medienecho bekommt denn diese Initiative?
Eigentlich schon recht vielen, also ich hab schon mal so dass diese Sache mit den Netzpolitik Medien in Österreich ein bisschen anders strukturiert ist, aber was es gibt an einschlägigen Kanälen und Zeitungen oder online Geschichten, da sind wir eigentlich recht,
Durchgehend vertreten mit mit fast jeder Presseaussendungen, die wir machen. Und ähm ja, es ist dann halt,
Immer schwieriger wirklich in den Mainstream zu kommen, wobei wir waren auch schon in Zeit im Bild, also dem, was bei euch die Tagesschau ist und äh in anderen großen Medien, also und Krone bringt uns auch immer wieder, das heißt sogar in den Populismus haben wir es geschafft, im Grunde könnte man eh
zufrieden sein.
Okay.
Und das ist jetzt zu äh die eine Front gewesen mit der Verfassungsklage, aber wir haben natürlich noch eine zweite Front und zwar die Bürgerinitiative, die wir gegen die,
europäische Richtlinie zur,
VDS gemacht haben. Ähm ich habe darüber auch das letzte Mal geredet, eben diese diese große Bühne zu, die wir auf äh Zeichnen mit AT, äh wo eben auch der Titel Cordoba zwei Punkt null herkam von der letzten Sendung,
und da hat sich auch was getan,
Ähm ich muss mal zuerst anfangen mit einem Ratum von mir selbst, weil ich habe in der letzten Sendung gemeint, dass wir ja schon ein Heering zugesichert hätten,
für die nächsten Petitionsausschuss, das war falsch, äh es hat zwar geheißen, dass wir eines bekommen, aber beschlossen war das noch nicht. Und ähm der, wir waren jetzt schon mal in zwei Ausschüssen mit unserer Bürgerinitiative,
Der erste war am zwölften März, das war vor unserer letzten Sendung und der zweite war, am einunddreißigsten Mai, der ist jetzt,
ähm zwischen den zwei Sendungen gewesen. Und äh ja, im Grunde sind wir bei beiden Ausschüssen gerade mal zusammen zehn Minuten behandelt worden,
und im letzten Ausschuss wurden wir abgeschoben an den Justizausschuss, womit unser Anliegen formal als behandelt gilt und unsere Bürgerinitiative mal abgeschlossen ist. Mehr Unterschriften können wir nicht sammeln,
Und wir halten bei dem historischen Stand von hundertsechstausendsiebenundsechzig Unterschriften.
Wahnsinnig viel. Ähm die wir jetzt mal haben und die jetzt mal so stehen und mehr sammeln können wir nicht und jetzt liegt's eigentlich am Justizausschuss über dieses Anliegen zu entscheiden.
Und äh weil wir da eben also wie wie diese letzte Petitionsausschusssitzung ähm zustande gekommen ist, war auch irgendwie lustig, weil wir waren irgendwie der allerletzte Tagesordnungspunkt Nummer neununddreißig. Also ganz am Ende der Sitzung,
äh wir wussten aber schon vorab, was dabei rauskommen wird, weil die zwei Regierungsparteien eine Stunde vorm Ausschuss eben schon mehr oder weniger fit
Festgelegt haben, dass man uns eher abschiebt, weil das ist eine heiße Geschichte irgendwie. Wir wissen nicht genau, was wir da sollen, geben wir das mal an den Justizausschuss.
Und dort sind wir jetzt eben. Ähm die Justizausschuss, der nächste tagt am einundzwanzigsten Juni,
und wir haben eigentlich sofort am nächsten Tag, nachdem wir da hin abgeschoben wurden,
eine neue Kampagne geboren, die auch irgendwie am selben Tag gleich online ging,
Zeichnen mit Artikel, dann kann man das sehen und zwar fordern wir dazu auf, die Abgeordneten im Justizausschuss anzuschreiben,
und die einfach mal äh freundlich darauf hinzuweisen, dass sie direkte Demokratie ernst nehmen sollen und auf die zwei Anliegen der Bürgerinitiative hinzuweisen,
Und ja, da haben wir jetzt mal diese äh sechsundzwanzig Abgeordneten plus unsere Parlamentspräsidentschaft,
mit Kontaktdaten und Bild angefügt. Ihr kennt wahrscheinlich die Software, das ist dasselbe, was bei Acta und bei PNR eingesetzt wurde, nur ein bisschen resigned.
Und ja, im Grunde genommen schauen wir mal, was dabei rauskommt. Also, ich muss sagen, von den, von den Rückmeldungen her,
Das Ganze ist ja irrsinnig spannend, dieses dieses ich schreibe deine Abgeordneten an, ja? Ein Freund von mir hat, dass sie genannt, was wir da tun,
ähm Ana Morphe Demokratie so im Sinne von einer für Substanzen, sowas wie Glas. Das sind nicht wirklich Feststoffe,
ähm die sind enorm zäh, wie zum Beispiel in einer Fensterscheibe, ringt ja eigentlich nach unten über mehrere hundert Jahre,
Und die sind zwar bei weitem nicht flüssig, aber auch nicht wirklich fest. Diese Stoffe. Und einer muss sie meint sozusagen
Du hast dieses starre parlamentarische System, wo irgendwie alles intransparent ist und die einzelnen Politiker sich hinter ihren Parteien verstecken,
und du versuchst halt, es ein bisschen bisschen flüssiger zu machen, indem du die Meinung des einzelnen Bürgers verbindest mit der Meinung des einzelnen Politikers,
Darstellst und versuchst sozusagen mit mit einfachen Kontaktieren so ein bisschen die die Einzelperson raus zu lösen aus diesem Ganzen.
Ich finde irgendwie, das ist ein netter Begriff, der dieses Konzept beschreibt, was wir da tun.
Ob's dann wirklich mal was bringt, werden wir sehen. Ich habe das mal auf Netzkinder verblockt, wo sie mit dem Konzept meinen und auf Zeichnen mit der kann man sehen, wie so die Lage ist, aber man muss
Also die meisten Antworten, die wir bekommen, sind dann äh mit Textbausteinen aus Parteizentralen.
Also es äußert sich vielleicht ein Sprecher jeder Partei, der dann sagt, ja eh
aber teilweise wirklich ja sehr schlechte Textqualität. Man hat nicht wirklich das Gefühl, dass sich die Politiker selbst damit beschäftigen, außer man ruft wirklich an und redet mal eine halbe Stunde mit ihnen, dann sind sie auf einmal einsichtig, aber das kann man halt auch nur begrenzt machen.
Ja. Wir haben noch zwei Themen.
Wir haben noch zwei Themen. Genau, die wollen wir jetzt auch noch aufgreifen.
Ja. Zwar das erste äh der Internetprovider Kabel Deutschland hat äh bekannt gegeben, also haben jetzt irgendwie neue AGBs,
und sagen äh in ihren Vertragsbedingungen lädt ein Kunde an einem Kalendertag, ein Gesamtdatenvolumen von mehr als zehn Gigabyte herunter.
Kann Kabel Deutschland ihm äh die zur Verfügung stehende Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit ausschließlich für Anwendungen bis zum Ablauf des selben Tages auf hundert
Kilobit pro Sekunde für den Downstream begrenzen. Das heißt, ähm sie machen gezieltes,
ausbremsen von Anwendungen ab, sobald du mehr als zehn äh Gig am Tag äh Traffic.
Gestaltet hast.
Welchen Zeitraum dann auf diesen Tag oder auf aha.
Den Rest des Tages, ja. Ähm klingt zunächst.
Und musst du diese diese zehn Gigabyte egal auf welchem Wege oder auch über das, was sie als Foulsharing bezeichnen, äh gesogen haben.
Ähm ich denke, dass sie äh also die die Formulierung würde bedeuten, dass es auf egal welchem Wege ist,
Und ähm deren Sorge ist oder worauf es abzielt, ist natürlich ganz klar. Es zielt auf die ab, die irgendwie Massen,
Durch Fightsharing da generieren und und das, was sie da als Flatrate bekommen, ähm irgendwie an die Grenzen,
jener Mischkalkulation bringen, die sich ja dahinter verbirgt, den Leuten eine Flatrate zu geben.
Ähm dass das gemeine, antwortete, also zunächst klingt's ja, ich meine zehn Gig, sollte eigentlich auch reichen,
niemand braucht mehr C, mehr als zehn Gigabyte an einem Tag würde Bill Gates sagen, ähm die ähm.
Also.
Ich mache ein ich mache ein,
Also ich komme im Schnitt nicht auf zehn Gig-Traffic am Tag, aber ich komme auch nicht sehr weit da runter, wenn ich mir meine meine kleine Vorratsdatenspeicherung in der Fritzbox.
Ähm das Gemeine ist ja eher also,
Zu sagen wir, wir limitieren den Traffic, das ist ja eine ähm eine Maßnahme, die wir sehr, die wir von den Telefonprovidern kennen. Du, Tim Master, regelmäßig Bekanntschaft mit.
Ja, allerdings.
Du machst die, du machst die fünf Gig voll und dann ist das Internet langsam.
Genau, beziehungsweise unbenutzbar.
Nur unbenutzbar und das ist aber dann generell der Fall für alle Anwendungen. Und nicht nur für ähm.
Für bestimmte. In diesem Falle sagen sie halt für ausschließlich für Fallschellen da begrenzt wirst. Ähm.
Wir definieren sie.
Das werden sie in ihren äh äh in ihren Regeln, auf ihren äh auf ihren ähm DPI-Boxen definieren, was jetzt Fight Sharing ist und was nicht.
Gut, aber man muss ja auch wissen, was man sozusagen vermeiden muss.
Da werden sie schon wissen, was sie da machen. Da werden sie schon, das ist jetzt nicht so schwer zu sehen, also die Liste der äh der Fall Sharing Dienste kann's ja auch einfach ähm,
Also Liste der Dienste ist ja äh begrenzt. Ähm die üblicherweise genutzten Ports sind bekannt.
Wenn es um um Maßnahmen geht, ist jetzt keine Schwierigkeit selektiv zu drosseln. Wenn du es jetzt ernsthaft darauf anlegen möchtest, ja?
Ähm.
Sagen wir mal, sprechen wir mal das Wort aus. Gemeint ist bittet.
Ich weiß ja nicht mal, ich glaube, Kabel Deutschland hat doch eh so einen so einen grottigen Upstream, macht da überhaupt jemand ernsthaft Bitholen mit? Aber okay, sie will wahrscheinlich meinen sie betörend, ja.
Was heißt schon ernsthaft? Also ähm.
Ich meine, bitterin treffe, kann sich mittlerweile auch ganz gut verstecken. Ich weiß nicht, wie sehr die DPI äh Gerätehersteller da mittlerweile mitgezogen sind, aber in dem Moment, wo man eben,
nur auf verschlüsselten Traffic äh ersetzt, also die Verschlüsselung ist ein bisschen übertrieben, also was bei bitteren stattfindet, ist mehr so eine Verschleierung, weil er da
RC vier als Algorithmus zum Einsatz kommt, das ist jetzt nicht so mega und knackbar, aber es geht ja jetzt hier auch nicht um.
Genau, es geht halt dadrum, dass einfach das Paket das Leben nicht mehr so ohne weiteres anzusehen ist, was denn Sinn und Zweck der ganzen Sache ist und auch bei den ports.
Sehr flexibel, also
die Kleinsten in der Lage, sich jederzeit äh zufällig einen neuen Port geben zu lassen, also da bin ich mir jetzt nicht ganz so sicher. Das heißt nicht, dass ich das jetzt für unmöglich halte, dass man bitteren Traffic als Seuchen erkennt. Da gibt's sicherlich äh auch noch andere Methoden,
ja. Was halten wir jetzt davon?
Wäre, die erste Methode wäre, da ballert einer auf einem nicht äh nicht äh definierten Port die ganze Zeit durch die Gegend,
und ähm das relativ,
relativ penetrant, also es ist wenn du da wenn du einfach mal ein bisschen genauer drauf schaust, wirst du jetzt schon wissen. Und dann schaust du dir halt einfach irgendwann lest du halt den Anschluss auf, okay, Fallshering blocken und dann macht der einfach mal zack alle zu Bums,
bremst einfach mal alles aus, weil für den normalen Nutzer, wenn du dem einfach seine seine äh Destination achtzig Verbindungen irgendwie ähm durchgehen lässt, dann ist er erstmal zufrieden.
Gut, wie bewerten wir das jetzt?
Zu bewerten ist das folgendermaßen in meinen Augen. Also es gab ja es gab ja dann schon welche, die sagten, ja okay und das ist jetzt wirklich eine eine humane Maßnahme. Ähm,
Ich würde an der Stelle echt sagen, ich bin weniger damit zufrieden.
Auch wenn es für den Nutzer vielleicht in Ordnung in Ordnung her ist, dass ihm nicht das ganze Internet langsam auffällt, sondern nur diese,
spezielle Anwendung. Ich fände es weniger schlimm, wenn sie für den gesamten Tag alles drosseln würden, als wenn sie das Fallsharing, nur das drosseln würden. Zwar aus folgendem Grunde, was jetzt die also es wird nicht lange dauern.
Bis eventuell der nächste Sharehoster sich bei Kabel Deutschland meldet und sagt, Freunde, hör mal, ihr habt ja hier, ihr drosselt ja, ne,
was braucht ihr eigentlich so an monatlicher Überweisung, damit ihr beim, bei mir nicht drosselt? Egal, wie viele Leute runterladen?
Und das ist ja genau da fängt ja das Problem der Netznetralitätsdebatte immer wieder an, dass es darum geht, dass ähm wenn,
du konkrete Dienste, Anbieter oder sonst was, äh betriffst, dass das und und das nicht,
alles beziehst und an, sondern anfängst zu diskriminieren, dass sich dann da die Möglichkeit bieten sollte, ähm.
Die Option bieten sollte, da ähm noch geheimere Absprachen oder oder auch ganz öffentliche Absprachen zu machen. Und dann wirklich zu einer Diskrimination der Anbieter
nicht nur der Dienste, sondern der Anbieter untereinander ähm zu führen. Insofern will ich sagen, aus,
aus Netz recht Netzperspektive wäre es wahrscheinlich besser, wenn sie einfach alles langsam machen würden, weil dann würden sie wenigstens nicht diskriminieren.
Ja, ich freue mich auch, warum, warum sie nicht einfach dazu übergehen, äh die Verträge entsprechend anders zu machen. Ich meine, wenn sie da irgendwie ein Limit äh haben wollen, dann sollen sie das doch von vornherein äh als als solchen Vertrag verkaufen und wenn jemand wirklich totlimited haben will
dann soll er äh entsprechend auch dafür den Preis zahlen können.
Die sind ja nicht in der Lage, die wirklich totly unlimited zu liefern.
Wenn wenn du jetzt was also ich habe hier, du hast, glaube ich, gleiche Leitung wiegt, was fuffzig MB Down oder bist du schon auf hundert?
Nee, geht das schon mit dem hundert?
Also kannst du weiß ich nicht, aber ich ich hätte, wenn es ginge, hättest du es wahrscheinlich.
Sofort es geht, ja.
Die äh die Sache ist, wenn du wenn du ausrechnest, wenn du das jetzt über einen Monat auslasten würdest. Die Anzahl an Gigabyte, die das, die du theoretisch bekommen könntest, ähm.
Und das würde jetzt einfach mal alle machen, die so einen Anschluss haben. Das kann halt natürlich die äh da der Internet-Provider in der Stelle nicht liefern, weil der selber gar nicht so ein dickes,
So ein dickes Kabel hat.
Ja gut, dann sollen sie mir nichts verkaufen, was sie nicht liefern können. Das ist das, was ich meine. Ja, also wenn wenn sie da Limitierungen haben, dann sollen sie die mal genau benennen und dann soll das eben auch in dem Kundenvertrag äh konkret drinstehen. Und das ist ja nicht das Ding. Ich meine
bei meinem Mobilfunkvertrag gibt's ja auch ein Limit. So. Das liegt halt bei,
Fall bei fünf Gigabyte im Monat, ja, wo ich eben weiß, das reicht in dreißig Prozent der Fälle für mich nicht aus, ja? Ich kann damit leben,
dass diese Limitierung gibt, wenn die den Vertrag konkret drin steht, vor allem wenn ich dann die Möglichkeit habe, im Zweifelsfall einfach mir ein weiteres Paket von fünf Gigabytes,
kaufen, wenn ich's brauche, was in meinem Fall halt nicht geht, dass das eigentliche, was mich daran stört, ja, weil das verstehe ich irgendwie nicht. Ich meine, die Leute wollen das Produkt benutzen. Ja, okay. Sollen sie doch bitte.
Wenn das halt sich nur bis zu einem bestimmten Datenvolumen finanzieren lässt mit dem äh vereinbarten Geldbetrag. Naja dann halt mehr,
So ist es.
Die Problematik, die dann natürlich so ein bisschen Auftritt ist, ähm,
Du beginnen würdest oder die die nächste Herausforderung, die sich dir dann stellt, sagen wir mal, du hast halt irgendwie sowas wie fünfzig Gigabyte schnell und danach wird dein Internet irgendwie auf sechstausender DSL runtergefahren und du möchtest halt am Monat Monatsersten
ähm irgendwie vierzig Gigabyte runterladen und die sind aber nicht zeitkritisch.
Weil, also was auch immer das jetzt sei, also ich will jetzt kein Beispiel nehmen, aber sagen wir oder so etwas wie Nachtdownloads, ja? Ähm so und dann möchtest du natürlich irgendwie die die Möglichkeit haben.
Sozusagen. Äh ja, jetzt habe ich aber hier nachdownload und der ist nicht kritisch. Gleichzeitig möchte ich aber während dieser Nacht downloaden, langsam dahin dümpelt, damit damit möchte ich jetzt nicht mein schnelles äh limitiertes Volumen äh abnutzen.
Verstehst du, folgst du mir noch?
Ich ich folge dir, verstehen ist was anderes.
Gleichzeitig möchte ich aber äh noch hier siebenhundert MB, die möchte ich jetzt schnell runterladen. Das heißt, du möchtest, du müsstest irgendwie ein Interface dazu bekommen, deine Routen äh zu priorisieren und zu sagen, äh,
Was ich jetzt gerade hier auf, auf mache, das kann ruhig limitiert sein, auf langsames DSL, weil das ist nicht zeitkritisch. Ähm die Lenux Distribution brauche ich erst in drei Wochen,
Gleichzeitig möchte ich aber hier diesen Upload, den ich gerade zur Meta-Ebene-Server mache mit höchster Geschwindigkeit haben.
Ja, ich kann die nicht ganz folgen. Also das möchtest du, dass das.
Das wäre die das wäre die, dass wir die nächste logische Konsequenz, wenn du sagst, du machst jetzt wirklich für den für den Heimanwender ein Volumen,
Beschränktes, schnelles Internet.
Du ja verhindern möchtest, dass du irgendwie zu Hause sitzt und sagst, Mist, ich habe schon wieder meine fünfzig Gig aufgebraucht und für den Rest der drei der des Monats habe ich gar kein schnelles Internet mehr.
Ich möchte einfach nur, dass die, dass die Anbieter einfach äh äh ein ehrliches, einen ehrlichen Vertrag aufsetzen. Ich meine, wenn sie von Flatrate reden, das ist aber keine Flatrate ist, dann sollen sie's halt nicht so nennen. Weil es ist keine Flatrate.
Doch, du hast ja die ganze Zeit Internet, wird nur irgendwann langsamer. Mehr Hotline, ich.
Na ja gut, ich meine, die Definition des Wortes Fleträt ist wahrscheinlich schon komplett äh äh verbrannt, ja, aber äh im Kern sagt das fester Preis und äh keine Aussagen zum Traffic, so.
All you can leadch.
Genau, all you can lead, ne? So, so lange bis das Buffet äh halt alle ist, ne, so. Und das ist halt nicht die Wahrheit, ne, so und dann dann sollen sie's einfach klar äh äh definieren, weil so,
hast du recht,
schleicht sich einfach von hinten dann eben theoretisch die Möglichkeit ein, dass das äh dass diese Zugänge dann eben nochmal ungerecht monetarisiert werden, aber Kern,
weiß ich jetzt nicht so richtig, worüber ich mich gerade aufregen soll.
Nee, ich denke mal, es ist jetzt noch nicht so der, der, der absolute Aufreger, ne, aber so so wehret den Anfängen. Thomas, was sagst du dazu?
Ähm habe ich wenig zu sagen. Ich weiß auch gerade nicht, wie das bei unseren Providern aussieht. Ich habe nur gemerkt, jetzt diese diese eher kleinen Provider,
Weniger, glaube ich, weil da ist einige schneller, aber die Großen, wie UPC, da hast du definitiv irgendwie egal, wie schnell die Internetverbindung ist, es gibt so
Mit gläserner Decke und über die kommst du nicht.
Und es gibt nur scheiß Upload hier. Also das ist wirklich, wirklich schlimm. Ähm ich habe hier einen äh nicht einmal ein Mbit ab und es gibt auch außer synchrone Verbindungen fast keine andere Möglichkeit, da irgendwie mehr zu kriegen.
Ja, aber das ist halt genau das Problem, ne. Also wenn wenn jetzt einfach in Abhängigkeit von wie ich das Netz nutze, äh es mal schnell und mal langsam ist, da wird es wirklich,
schwierig. So, ja. Wenn das Problem
Traffic ist, dann sollen sie das einfach klar sagen und eine Ansage machen von vorneherein und dann steht das auch genauso im Vertrag und dann weiß ich auch, was ich
und wenn ich der Meinung bin, ich brauche mehr, dann sollen sie halt da einen Weg schaffen. Entweder zahlt man generell mehr oder man hat halt da mehrere Stufen, die man aktivieren kann,
dass ich jetzt irgendwas starte und auf einmal ist es langsam und der einzige Grund, warum es langsam ist, weil weil irgendein Systemadministrator da äh an einer Schraube gedreht hat, wo ich ja auch keinerlei Transparenz darüber habe, ja,
stellen wir vor, man das auch irgendwie Softwareentwickler,
Auf der einen wie auf der anderen Seite, also entweder jetzt als Kunde eines solches Providers oder eben letzten Endes als ähm derjenige, der auf der anderen Seite steht, der dann auch äh äh von von seinen Kunden wiederum gesagt bekommt, na ja, das performt ja hier alles gar nicht und er ist irgendwie überhaupt nicht Schuld daran und kann auch gar nichts daran ändern.
Das ist halt einfach äh das prangere ich an. So, jetzt haben wir das genug angeprangert.
Genug angefangen hat. Und jetzt kommen wir zum zum letzten Ding, was ich noch mit reinnehmen wollte,
Thomas, du hast das wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen, der Google Mitarbeiter Tim Bray.
Schlägt einen neuen HTTP Statuscode vor. Ja, HTDP-Status Codes ähm sind ja äh quasi die also ähm,
Da antwortet der Webserver mit
wenn also auf die Anfrage, ja? Es kommt irgendwie es geht irgendwie los, so hallo und dann kriegt man irgendwie einen Zweihundert zurück und dann äh lass mal, lass mal sehen und dann gibt's diese diese Umleitung, ja, also drei null eins Move permanent Lee. Das heißt, ähm dem dem dem Zugreifen wird gesagt,
das, was du hier suchst, wurde permanent für für immer woanders hinbewegt und diese, diese Status, kurz, grade die Move permanent Lee oder ähm,
temporäre und so, die helfen Google sehr viel, weil die natürlich dann sowas wie Move Permanently, ist halt einfach deine Garantie,
den den man ja so wie der Fachmann sagt, ja Herr Fachmann, spricht von Juice, ja. Äh also dein deine deine Suchmaschinen ähm.
Den Patch-Rank oder was zu behalten, wenn du Content an eine andere Stelle bewegst, ja? Und ähm.
Genauso wie irgendwie vier null vier Nordfounds, sagt der Suchmaschine, okay er hat sich erledigt, hier brauche ich nicht mehr zu gucken, kann ich streichen, ja
und und jetzt kommt also aus der Google Ecke dieser Vorschlag ähm den vier fünf eins, Anne Valable for Legal Reasons. Das hat ja so eine kleine äh Special geschrieben und äh schlägt das vor.
Und jetzt ist finde ich eine sehr interessante Sache, da mal drüber nachzudenken, ob man wirklich in HTTP.
Also es wäre auf jeden Fall ein Dammbruch, wenn wir das hätte, wenn wir irgendwie Legals als Statuscode in das HTTP-Protokoll mit reinbringen.
Ich glaube, es ist zwar irrsinnig traurig, aber notwendig. Ich meine, du machst einfach nur technisch sichtbar, was da, was da Sache ist,
Und ähm dann kam er wenigstens ein bissel auch ähm ja die Zensur, die herrscht detektieren und muss nicht immer von technischen Fehlern ausgehen, also
dann ist es halt grade auch vielleicht für den unbedarften User, der überhaupt keine Ahnung hat, dass hier irgendwas zensiert wird, kann man das vielleicht dann auch eher noch mehr sichtbar machen. Und hatten Basswörter dafür. Und ähm ich glaube, dass das ist irrsinnig traurig, dass wir so einen Statuscode brauchen, aber
Ich glaube, es ist notwendig.
Ja, ich meine, das ist in gewisser Hinsicht eine sehr äh ehrliche Geschichte. Ich erinnere mich hier noch an unsere Debatte als Twitter, äh da so sein neues Behavior mal definiert hat so nach dem Motto, na ja, hier so Zensur findet statt, ja, können wir nichts gegen machen. Die Rechtslage ist einfach da
da, äh so der Tweet äh äh darf in dem Land dann nicht äh verfügbar gemacht werden, aber in anderen halt schon
dadurch entsteht eben indirekt auch eine gewisse Transparenz darüber, dass da eben eine solche Zensur auch stattgefunden hat
Hier äh ist es das Gleiche und es ist im Prinzip ja auch eine extrem gute Erklärung. Ja, ich meine, wenn jetzt ein PDF-Dokument verlinkt ist,
und es ist äh verboten worden. Unabhängig davon,
ob das jetzt eine richtige Entscheidung war, aber es ist dann halt ein juristischer Fakt und du als Betroffener kannst ja jetzt auch nicht sehr viel mehr machen,
kannst du jetzt diese Datei löschen, dann läuft das eine in einen Notfound und dann ist halt der Link irgendwie tot und und äh im Prinzip werden automatisierte Systeme, denen dann eben als nicht existent werden,
Ja? Wenn du aber sagst, äh,
Ja, den gibt's grad nicht, weil muss ich halt sperren. Das kann sich ja später auch wieder ändern, ja, sagen wir mal, du kriegst irgendwie so eine einstweilige äh Verfügung oder so eine Abmahnung rein, musst jetzt irgendwie äh ein Dokument äh runternehmen.
Also meinst du, vier fünf zwei.
Ja, das könnte man irgendwie äh beliebig weitertreiben, ja? Oder warum nicht auch eine Anne Welle bevor illegal.
Also ähnlich wie ähnlich wie du argumentierte, auch der Peter Pixa, den ich hier an dieser Stelle natürlich herzlich grüße. Ähm der nämlich sagte, das Schöne wäre, du könntest das dann auch Länder,
spezifisch machen, das meintest du ja implizit auch mit mit Twitter. Ähm die Frage ist nur, es gibt halt eine ganze Menge Länder, ne.
Und ähm das kriegst du so einfach nicht mehr ähm.
Also doch man kann das schon irgendwie, man kann hinkriegen, woher Leute kommen. Das kann man schon irgendwie über IP-Adressen und so weiter detektieren. Und man hätte dann noch diesen schönen Nebenaspekt, dass man eventuell über VPNs in anderen Ländern,
sich dann irgendwie bewegen kann. Die Frage ist, wie realistisch ähm
ist es tatsächlich, dass jemand das macht und das mit irgendwie allen hundertfünfzig Ländern oder was die die Welt hat, ernsthaft da die die Situation monitort, ja?
Ja, also mit Länderunterscheidungen das ist jetzt nochmal ein anderes Thema. Wie gesagt, grundsätzlich äh äh ich bin für mehr Semantik und wenn man irgendwie nicht bereit ist, eine Ressource aufzugeben, nur weil sie einem jetzt gerade verboten wurde, ne, also wenn man sozusagen nicht
dauerhaft aufgeben will, dann einen entsprechenden Statuskurs zu haben, mit dem man das dann auch explizit äh markieren kann, finde ich jetzt keinen Fehler, ne? Ich meine, das äh ich bin grundsätzlich für
mehr Statuskurs.
Ja und es ist auch ähm der erste Schritt irgendwie doch noch an die Inhalte ranzukommen. Also der Umgehung. Dann habe ich halt irgendwie die Seite, wo ich mir gerade die tandic äh PDF-Dokuments anschauen kann oder was auch immer.
Also ich find's gut, wenn er noch irgendwie ein ein Hashtag von der Datei mit rausgeben würde oder so einen Magnetlink oder so direkt.
Und was ihr noch nicht gesagt habt, woher die eigentlich die Zahl für den Code kommt, das ist ja von dem Buch Fahne vier, fünf eins.
Ja, stimmt. Erklär das mal genauer. Ich habe das nur äh.
Ich hab's auch nicht gelesen, aber ich glaube.
Sinne in dem.
Ein äh ein Buch und ich begebe mich auf dünnes Eis, aber ich glaube äh vierhunderteinundfünfzig fahren hat, ist die Temperatur, wo Bücher brennen,
Glaube ich und sprich, es ist auch so ein Roman über Zensur und und insofern ist die Nummer für den Statuscode eigentlich eine Referenz auf Bücherverbrennungen und das passt eigentlich ganz gut.
So ist ein Buch von Ray Breatbery, der vor äh zehn Tagen verstorben ist.
Auch das noch. Vor zehn Tagen hat da zufällig der Timbray den Vorschlag gemacht, nee, ist noch nicht ganz zehn Tage.
Nicht Ganja, aber sozusagen im Nachgang. Ja, also vielleicht war das sozusagen äh ihm zu Ehren äh hatte diese Zahl gezogen,
Ist auf jeden Fall noch zu haben, vierhunderteinundfünfzig. Tim Bray ist ja auch ein ganz alter Hase, bevor der bei Google äh äh mitgearbeitet hat, der ist äh extrem bekannt in dieser XML,
Spezifikationsszene auch, also das ist sozusagen jetzt nicht irgendjemand, sondern das ist äh jemand, der im Bereich Webdefinition äh ein großer Name ist.
Naja, wir können das ja mal hier einfach so im Raum äh stehen lassen. Ich äh finde das einen pfiffigen Vorschlag. So,
Wir endlich ans Ende gekommen sind dieser überlangen Ausgabe hier von Lokbuch Netzpolitik. Wir haben mal ja herzlich überzogen.
Acht Themen, zwei Gäste, also.
Das muss wohl sein.
Das muss mal so sein. Ein eine bunte Unterhaltungsgala.
Also ich könnte noch, ich bin noch.
Ja, das ist äh schön, dass du da neulich äh ermüdet bist.
Thomas, vielen Dank für deinen äh Beitrag. Wie gesagt, Netzkinder AT, da äh kommt die österreichische Perspektive zum Vorschein, richtig?
Ja, ja, vielen Dank und gerne immer wieder.
Produziert da.
Sechs Folgen sind's jetzt und äh ja, es kommt sicher noch mehr.
Gibt's da eine Regelmäßigkeit oder nur eine Unregelmäßigkeit?
Ähm.
Eine regelmäßige Unregelmäßig.
Publikationsdruck. Ähm keine Sorge. Da wird äh doch irgendwie mindestens einmal pro Monat was Neues kommen. Ähm besser wäre, wenn's irgendwie so alle zwei Wochen wäre, aber ich schaue, wie ich das einpennen kann.
Okay. Ja und bei uns, wie gehabt, jede Woche neu, Logbuch Netzpolitik, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, das war's, wir sagen tschüss. Auf Wiederhören. Bis bald.
Auf Wiederhören.